the House Judiciary Committee Chairman
is talking about impeaching the Attorney
General who's accused of interfering in
cases on president Trump's behalf a
federal prosecutor told the committee
yesterday that he was pushed by what he
calls the highest levels of the Justice
Department to go easy on the president's
longtime friend and advisor that's Roger
stone the testimony followed a federal
appeals court ruling ordering a judge to
dismiss a criminal case against retired
General Michael Flynn mr. Trump's first
national security adviser Nancy Cordes
has a president's response I'm very
happy about general Flynn the president
hailed the appeals court ruling as Flynn
conveyed his joy to radio host Rush
Limbaugh she doesn't think for me it's a
good thing for my family but it's really
a great a boost of confidence for the
American people in our justice system
Flynn pleaded guilty twice to lying to
the FBI about his calls with a Russian
official but Attorney General William
Barr moved to get the case dismissed
last month saying the FBI should never
have interviewed Flynn Bell Barr does
regularly lie in ways that impact
official action a hearing about Barr
Wednesday turned heated at times the
American people deserve to know the
truth
as Democrats accused him of repeated
political interference he has shown us
that there is one set of rules for the
president's friends and another set of
rules for the rest of us just this month
they argued Barr ordered the removal of
protesters to facilitate a presidential
photo-op and fired a US attorney
overseeing cases involving Trump
associates
Donald Eyre is a former Deputy Attorney
General under George HW Bush he has a
personal belief that the president
should be above the law and he has
worked very hard to achieve that
assistant US attorney Erin szalinski
described how his team was pushed to
recommend a lighter sentence for a long
time Trump friend Roger stone I was told
that there was heavy political pressure
from the highest levels of the
Department of Justice to cut Roger stone
to break Republicans argued Barr was
being maligned and now they're targeting
administration officials in
case attorney general bar for merely
acting within the scope of their duties
bar will have a chance to defend himself
next month after several false starts he
has agreed to testify before the House
Judiciary Committee on July 28th but the
chairman of that committee Jerry Nadler
now says he may pursue impeachment
charges against Barr Anthony what
thickens Nancy thank you